it wouldn't be completely unprecedented
to hear that you can effectively buy
ambassadorships in American politics and
we heard from Donald Trump during his
campaign that he was going to stop the
lobbyists status quo that he was going
to end the revolving door of influence
peddlers that he was going to drain the
swamp we heard all of that stuff but it
turns out that it's not actually
happening that won't come as a surprise
to many people in our audience and we
now have learned about a new ambassador
an ambassador to South Africa who it has
not been officially announced yet but
we've learned that it is going to be
Lana Marx
Lana Marx has no diplomatic experience
she works making $100,000 luxury
handbags she's lied about her past
accomplishments like for example she
claimed to have played in the French
Open she didn't it's unclear if she
played in the 1985 Maccabi Games as she
claimed she's accused of not paying her
lawyers and accountants and landlords
and employees which actually sounds a
lot like what Donald Trump does as well
and she just so happens I'm sure it's
just a coincidence she just so happens
to be a member at Donald Trump's own
mar-a-lago Golf Club and Resort in
Florida now she is from South Africa so
that's something I guess that has some
connection to the place she is going to
be nominated to be ambassador for many
presidents do versions of this okay so
I'm not pretending for a second that
it's just Trump that that does this
Obama did it but the difference is when
Obama did it with people far more
qualified the right said it's favoritism
this is disgusting this should be
illegal if it's not but of course it's
not and President Obama should be
removed because it is clear evidence
that his loyalties lie somewhere other
than the United States Trump does it and
you have the usual enclaves of the
internet defending the decision with
comments like hey guys she could be
really qualified we are is the left
opposing the nomination merely because
she's a
because that would be wrong as if all of
a sudden their concern trolling about
misogyny from the left about Trump's
unqualified ambassador pic is actually
really the political issue at hand this
is disgusting it's not unique to Trump
but he did tell us he was going to stop
it yeah I mean I hope that she does
South Africa relations as well as she
does her handbags because those handbags
bags do look pretty nice yeah you just
think that in a country full of 320
million people we'd be able to find
better candidates out there like there
are only 200 countries for which you
have to send ambassador and we don't
even have it better is that all yeah
it's hard to imagine that this is the
right person and an underreported issue
by the way this it's related and it's a
good opportunity to bring it up I was
reading about it yesterday the
Department of Veterans Affairs Secretary
Robert Wilkie is refusing to share
documents linking agency officials to
Mara Lago very specifically so there's
cronyism in general but then there's
like really noticeable and pathetic
cronyism and and not literally nepotism
but sort of similar not trumps family
but some next layer removed of officials
at the agency connected to Donald
Trump's mar-a-lago and Wilkie is
refusing to hand information over to
Congress now at this point would it
matter of course not I mean yes Trump
said drain the swamp and he's not doing
it but his followers don't care and yes
it's cronyism but do you really think
that if a list was released of people at
the Department of Veterans Affairs
connected to Mara Lago that anybody is
going to hold Donald Trump accountable
it wouldn't even be the biggest scandal
on any specific day that it comes out
and it's abundantly clear that there's
just no appetite to hold the guy
accountable to this but in the meantime
Lana marks can somebody just tell me
other than being born in South Africa
which I don't even know that it counts
as a qualification what makes her
qualified to be ambassador to South
Africa like make the case for her
qualification I want to hear from
somebody about it
we'll have to see that during her
confirmation hearings I mean I'd like to
hear her talk about the biggest cash
crops in South Africa and their biggest
exports because I want to see her go
into detail
I would love to hear from her about that
and all other important issues to South
Africa